you know what I'm really sick of
I'm really sick of seeing influencers on here and I've got heaps of trolls
I am in all the forums so the trolls come to my account and then they go
ooh it's an awful man hating feminist and then they go and take all my videos
repost them and put them in forums
and then they send all the little troll friends to come and say
really meaningless stuff on my post
and then sometimes I go and look at who these trolls are following
and they're following the hot girl influences
they're following all these influences that we all know and that we all watch
and that we all love get ready with me etcetera
and if just one of these influences from time to time spoke more about feminism
patriarch inequality it's not that hard to do
it's not rocket science
like you could speak out on it a little bit more like why is this so Silo
like what are you doing like what is your purpose in this world
what is your purpose
are you happy to continue being a vessel for data collection
a vessel for consumerism
a vessel for advertisers to use and selling your body in that way
is that cause you can do that and I'm not against that
but is that your only purpose and meaning in life
like do you have any other things that you care about
is there has there ever occurred to you to use your platform
has it like I just
I just don't understand how
it would never occur to you that you got this incredible privilege
this incredible platform
all these people who are just hanging on your every word
and that you could use that to make the world better place
not one product at a time
but one idea at a time
you can do both you can be like influencer great
great job love that for you
happy for you but like you could do more
you could do but like right now
the I Place is invading rougher
the met and you're all commenting on Met Gala
they did it while the Met Gala was happening like
do you care
like do you have a conscience
do you ever think like wow
most people just have to show up on a Sunday and go to a rally
most people just have to like
try to scrape together some coffee money so that they can donate
like most people are just sharing to their Instagram Stories
hoping they're like a handful of friends and family see stuff and care enough
you have like millions of followers
like does it ever occur to you
does it ever occur to you is what I'd like to know